on parle beaucoup d'égalités de salaire
entre les femmes et les hommes dans
notre société mais s'il ya bien une
catégorie socioprofessionnelle ou ce
déséquilibre est flagrant c'est dans le
monde du sport de haut niveau c'est
précisément pour cette raison que la
double championne du monde de football
féminin avec les états unis megan
rapinoe a décidé de se rendre à la
maison blanche pour échanger avec le
président joe biden au sujet de
l'égalité où elle il faut que les choses
bougent
à titre de comparaison la meilleure
joueuse de l'équipe de france amandine
henry toucherait trois cent soixante
mille euros par an alors que qui vient
même map et brasserie près de 18
millions d'euros par an alors football
les femmes doivent-elles être payé
autant que les hommes les femmes doivent
peut-être d'être payé autant que les
hommes alors déjà j'ai entendu là déjà
ça commençait pas possible il à la merci
mon daniel d'éclat bonsoir chien c'est
une envie de voir ben non je suis
content de te voir et je parle beaucoup
de toi voilà donc ce qu'ont donc te voir
je sais qu'après tu veux après sur ton
sur rmc oui à 21h ce soir elle évite un
peu à la wii dont s'inquiète pas il ya
qu'à car il me lâche plus et se régaler
les deux c'est pas possible c'est devenu
aujourd'hui se lâchent plus et
tambouille cash
et oui ça fait plaisir beaucoup m'ont
mohcine ça me fait plaisir marrakech
alors cette histoire elle est folle moi
je voudrais qu'on les femmes
doivent-elles être pays autant que les
hommes dans le foot aujourd'hui j'ai vu
sur les réseaux sociaux
ça n'a pas arrêté tout le monde avait
son avis et ben moi je vous rêvez
redémarrer par vous adhérez vous dites
non sur le principe sur le papier et les
femmes doivent-elles être payés oui à
compétence égale salaire égal ça
normalement c'est une règle qui est
absolument immuable il se trouve que
dans le football que je ne connais pas
bien pardon pour les spécialistes mais
il me semble qu'à une réalité économique
qu'est que les hommes rapportent plus
d'argent que les femmes et que par
ailleurs il donc ils sont assez fins de
déterminer en fonction
donc j'imagine que en revanche une
revalorisation du salaire des femmes
actuellement dans le monde du football
je vous dit en fait les droits télé
doivent être revalorisées voit la femme
cartonne moi je vous dire les femmes
les saf et des 9 millions la coupe du
monde féminine
et c'est vrai que les droits coûte
beaucoup moins cher je vous raconter une
anecdote nous au départ sur direct 8
mon amie à mes meilleures amies qui
était le patron de direct 8 10 jeu
j'adore le football féminin il regardé
c'était pas du tout c'est qu'à l'époque
c'était il ya 15 ans et j'adore le
football féminin outils dont je suis
plus voilà il dit c'est vrai que
pourquoi on n'en voit pas la télé et il
est allé voir les dirigeants de la
fédération française de football et il
leur a dit pourquoi ya pas de football à
la télé vous de votre ball féminin l'an
dernier personne peut acheter les droits
et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont dit
si vous les voulez on vous donne les
matchs gratuitement 5 fr et si ça marche
eh ben on verra après donc pour vous
dire au départ les matchs de foot
féminin on les avait eus gratuit sur
direct 8
et ça fait des cartons d'audience ça
chez lui avec ce coup là il a fait un
coût énorme et ça a été très vite le
record d'audience tnt
il avait même un match à 19 heures avec
l'équipe de france donc un truc qui a
coûté 0
ça fait le record d'audience tnt après
tout le monde s'est jeté dessus alors
les droits des gens commenté mais c'est
vrai que c'est loin loin loin que ce
qu'il devrait être
daniel riolo vous vous dites oui bout
dit non déjà sur juste sur l'idée de
revaloriser les droits télé qui va
allait obliger un patron de chaîne à
mettre de l'argent à mes droits télé
s'il a permis d'émettre ce c'est bien
beau de dire il faut revaloriser
quelle est la personne qui va aller voir
vincent bolloré à canal ou je ne sais
qui donnait cola dans la terre ne m 6
exactement il ya tu sais qu'il faut
revaloriser tu vas mettre 100 millions
sur les droits du foot féminin mais ceci
non ça va pas quelle est cette personne
présentait moi la personne qui va
obliger un diffuseur
alors que plusieurs l'écriture et le
pari sur les quais vocation
internationale c'est le truc si c'est
pas chez les filles c'est que le
championnat qui coûte énormément
d'argent l'a vu chez les hommes voilà et
les championnats européens et coûte
énormément d'argent mais ce qui marche
dans le foot féminin sol etc ce sont
surtout les compétitions internationales
arrivent aux arrivants immédiatement à
l'intérêt du débat comme ça ça évitera
qu'on se chamaille troyen le football de
club ça n'a rien à voir il faut pas en
parler ça n'a aucune logique ni
économique
on peut même pas parler d'égalité ça là
puisqu'elle ne font pas du tout en fait
il ne faut pas le même travail n'est les
hommes et les femmes ne font pas le même
travail ne joue pas c'est comme si on
disait un artiste qui joue devant 100
personnes
il doit être payé le même tarif qu'un
mec qui joue
devant une salle de 5000 personnes ou
des gens qui font des concerts devant un
million de personne fin bref ça c'est
impossible
le vrai débat et d pour les équipes
nationales ouais et d'ailleurs morgan
rapino elle n'a pas dit autre chose
elle l a dit aujourd'hui il faut pas s'y
méprendre sur son discours megan rica ce
que j'ai dit à morgan parra dans mes
gars il faut pas se méprendre sur son
discours ll dis très simplement nous on
est championne du monde
pourquoi touche pas autant que les
hommes américains qui eux sont plutôt
mauvais on exactement
et là effectivement est la raison ne
peut que la soutenir c'est même moi même
je pensais même que c'était moi aussi je
croyais que c'était acté ouais je
trouvais j'aime et j'ai même trouvé
sympa pas normal et puis je ne crois pas
qu'en plus le football des hommes la
sélection au mail rapporte énormément
d'argent sur le côté logique économique
ce qui rapporte le plus je suis même pas
sûr parce que l'équipe féminine elle est
très connue à les y autorise à militer
c'est culturellement le foot américain
le foot féminin aux états unis est très
connue en france comment on va faire ça
on va demander à la fédération que tout
l'argent qui rentre aussi bien des
sélections hommes que femmes soient
ensuite partagé à part équivalente
moi je veux bien mais les joueurs on va
leur dire quoi parce qu'aujourd'hui les
joueurs il faut quand même le savoir
sont payés en droits d'image
donc l'argent qui rentre par le biais
des sponsors c'est parce que ma paix est
connu c'est parce que griezmann assure
amandine henry est très connu c'est une
fille super mais rapporte pas énormément
d'argent mais à la limite poussons le
raisonnement jusqu'au bout et donc ok vu
que c'est la fédération c'est une
délégation de service public
prenons l'argent essayons d'en donner
plus plus oui pourquoi pas mais dira
mbappé écoute mon grand si toi tu nous
rapporte pour votre titre de champion du
monde vous avez touché entre 300 et 400
mille euros en droits d'image
les filles elles ont touché beaucoup
moins elles ont fait quarts de finale
elles ont certainement touché trop peu
par rapport à un quart de finale ça
mériterait une réévaluation d'autant qu
effectivement là où tu avais raison si
elle sait que les audiences ont été plus
revient très intéressante et manque donc
là certainement qui a un travail à faire
de ce côté là mais parler d'égalité ça
c'est absolument aucun sens il faut pas
utiliser des mots qui n'ont pas de sens
alors gilbert des salaires colère je
suis entièrement désaccord avec daniel
le brésil aliments comme on dit douvres
le brésil où tu peux
mon petit peu le président battu battu
va comprendre le brésil c'est le plus
grand pour une fois tu va écouter
quelqu'un le grand pays de football
je vais écouter ça va être compliqué les
hommes les hommes brésilien les hommes
brésilien oui les joueuses brésilienne
touche maintenant la même chose mais la
fédération brésilienne a dit ce sera les
mêmes primes les mêmes avantages pour
les autres le championnat aussi alors
c'est difficile sinon impossible c'est
plutôt que d'attaquer comme si la vente
est non mais je quand je te dis que ça
va être difficile c'est juste qu'il va
falloir en parler aux joueurs au brésil
c'est le patron de la fédé secondes
en plus je te vois pas été trop loin la
fédé et là si ça leur est proposé et si
il y à une demande en ce sens forcément
il va falloir en parler avec tous les
acteurs concernés que les brésiliens les
faits c'est vrai tu as raison de le
souligner dans un pays de grande culture
footballistique
c'est un pas qui est intéressant mais je
trouve qu'il est encore plus légitime
aux états unis où vraiment à
berthierville de tête mais pourquoi pas
faire ce pas là au sein de la fédération
noël le graet j'imagine ne va pas
immédiatement allé dans ce sens parce
que lui il en est encore à les traiter
un petit peu comme des moins que rien vu
les dernières sorties général le graet a
dit qu'il regardait pas trop le foot
féminin
oui et puis a dit que de toute façon
elle pouvait se tirer les cheveux
si elle n'aimait pas la sélectionneuse
en place enfin bref il a été assez
méprisant à l'égard des des joueuses de
l'équipe de france mais bon ça de toute
façon il a été réélu triomphalement
oui c'est vrai donc voilà ce que vous
avez déjà parlé de ça avec une fille de
l'équipe de france personnellement non
par exemple de la fifa de la question
d'égalité homme femme alors d'alger et
lilith effectivement pour que les
différentes fédérations nationales face
voilà les gars vous êtes salariales bien
sûr mais je suis là soit on est d'accord
qu'on est pour d'une façon générale tous
métiers confondus tous corps confondus
sur les femmes gagnent autant que les
hommes quand même jeu
même plus sûr btp si megan rapinoe elle
va à la maison blanche c'est parce que
le 24 mars c'est le hic ok mais donc en
fait c'est le jour y compris les jours
de la paix par les japonais vont y croit
et que bp parce qu'effectivement aux
états unis c'est le 24 mars qu'une femme
américaine gagne autant que ce qu'un
homme a gagné en 2020 l'année d'avant
d'aller travailler deux mois presque 3
mois 4 1 pineau sa banque illico et
surtout de vous poser une question est
ce que par exemple si une présentatrice
d'une émission à femme dure à des
maillets ne présente pas les
chroniqueurs elle va vite présenté mais
voilà on est donc géraldine maillet
présente une émission et que son salaire
soit deux fois inférieur à celui de
cyril hanouna
alors ça c'est du château dinan est ce
que vous allez vous battre pour que le
salaire soit égal ouais je suis en effet
pour dominer comment est ce possible
avec lui poser de questions daniel
blaise m'arrête pas là encore la parole
même en étant les alizés je suis pour
globalement dans le secteur privé que
les écarts de salaire dépasse pas 2 ans
avant mais c'est surtout le monde entre
hommes également parce qu'elle ait
grandi style action compris entre 1
alors que ce que la question de donner
la date les régions différence que vous
posez entre géraldine et celle il se
pose aussi entre cyril et berna entre
cyril et nicolas faut qu'ils fassent le
même métier
bah oui oui si on fait une émission
nicolas ça d'accord mais ça vous posez
la question de comparer avec c'est parce
qu'il ya quelque chose qui s'évalue
assez facilement c'est tu fais de
l'audience où t'en fais pas je vous
rapporte de l'argent tu rapportes pas
l'émission si elle est présentée par
quelqu'un globe que cyril hanouna tmp je
pense qu'ils font la moitié de
l'audience
il est normal que quelque part il y ait
quelque chose qui le distingue daniel
donc je sois une femme
on a le même éthique et du cenipa
présentateur télé et ça n'est pas de
faire de l'audience justement leur
métier c'est de jouer inscrits par
selanne et de l'audience et de faire une
animation à la violence dans le football
si les gens qui viennent aussi la raison
daniel parce que le football a évolué
d'une certaine façon et est financée
aujourd'hui principalement par les
droits tv ce qui d'ailleurs dans les
sous-sols journée où ils ont les droits
tv vous êtes d'accord qu'il ya un
problème crâne est de la fédération
ailleurs dollars 1 milliard la dernière
fois les lots finalement on s'est
retrouvé avec media content il pouvait
pas payer de toute façon ce système là
mais ne marche ça n'est pas si et ne
marche pas comme ça je vous êtes
d'accord avec le système actuel vous
êtes du côté du mans je pense pas ça
esseulé je pense en plus que ça favorise
pas l'équité salariale y compris entre
joueurs madame garrido mes repères sur
le fait que l'équipe nationale française
alors fontaine je voulais trouver les
modalités de départ contre ce phénomène
avec le manager walter et les mêmes
monte alors excusez moi encore une fois
je peux entendre ce discours là et quand
j y prends l'exemple de la sélection du
brésil
je lui dis c'est pas parce que le brésil
l'a fait que forcément c'est une bonne
chose et je peux entendre et si vous
voulez bien entendre est entré dans un
débat que d'autres disent bah écoutez
moi à partir du moment où l'équipe de
france elle rapporte 100 et que l'équipe
de foot féminine rapporte 10 c'est pas
forcément logique qu'elles touchent
autant que les hommes
je vous promets que ce discours peut
également s'entendre même si pour vous
le mot égalité un très important la
langue française et m
drapeau c'était un essai comme c'est une
sorte de l'élan à qui on donnera
l'argentine équipe de france des hommes
elle rapporte sans match haché ou fait
en fait on fait comment on met on mets
moi soutient ces îliens les anglais les
norvégiens comment ils ont fait tous
ceux qui le font ni salariales est-ce
que forcément c'est une chose qui est
bien bien sûr des salariès qu'on peut
amorcer moi oui j'ai bien discuté des
relations
madame bardot est ce qu'on peut en
discuter se dire qu'au final c'est pas
forcément juste non plus que celui qui
rapporte beaucoup
nous ne touche pas plus que celui qui
rapporte ses pairs le problème de
l'homme et de la femme avait une vision
non sportives ton activité qui est
d'abord un sport vous dites coeur mais
ça fait bien ça n'est pas le cas alors
une coupe du monde une compétition
internationale et des cousines avoir une
activité sportive
si vous vous enlevez le snow une
réévaluation assurément et pénalités non
je terminais reviendrait valuation vous
parce que les audiences comme je l ai
dit tout à l'heure à un horizon très
bonne une réévaluation regarder la
finale aller câblée américaine c'est un
sens dans le cas de l'équipe de france
ça n'a pas version bas libéré daniel qui
doit y aller mon chéri dans merci
beaucoup merci montagne à l'inversé du
reviens quand tu vois on adore compte
hélas oui bah voila voila et je te
mettrai à côté du péruvien merci manière
de dire tu peux y aller mon chéri
aulnoye merci beaucoup daniel riolo qui
était avant tout j'aime alors d'accord
avec toi raguel les hommes et les femmes
doivent gagner la même chose pour des
métiers classiques et des métiers de
l'ormeau l'on parle de choses
complètement irrationnel c'est des stars
megan rapinoe elle-même c'est une star
elle gagne quatre cent mille euros par
an ce qui est déjà énorme et leurs
arguments c'est que elle gagne plus que
plein de joueurs de foot masculin qui
joue à dijon à ranger qui gagne 5000
10000 euros par mois donc là quand on
parle de star qu'est-ce qui régule sa
caisse qui régissent à s'élancer la
popularité c'est les ventes c'est les
ventes de maillots et c'est donc une
réalité économique soit centre cette
réalité là mais je pense pas que ce soit
saint quay les joueurs soit pas rémunéré
en fonction de ce qu'ils apportent
sportivement mais de ce qu'ils
rapportent en termes de 2000 à palerme
en simplicité sa large enfin c'est le
sport et que c'est pas bien
non pourquoi pas mais il faut baisser
les hommes augmenter les prix non mais
d'une façon générale mais ce qu'on fera
des finances ya risée le sport et non
m'est avis il y en a qui gagnent
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent grâce aux
rentrées au vos droits tv publicitaires
au contrat de charlie merchandizing et
autres c'est pour ça que vous avez un
neymar qui pendant la coupe du monde se
coiffe différemment à chaque match pour
que ça fasse des articles dans les
papiers alors que les stars mais le
studio c'est le système n'est pas une
modalité rationnelle de gestion
d'économie
parce qu'en réalité ce qu'apporte un
joueur ce que rapporte un joueur sur le
nez et un oeil à un moment donné sont
communes aux mines et dur avec ce que
les clubs vont opérer au détriment d'une
économie générale la dernière partie des
missions là qu'on va voir ce qu'on
pensait téléspectateurs ce qui sont
beaucoup plus intéressant non oui à 30%
non à 60% ce score prend ce score assez
mieux que jean luc mélenchon
non mais parce que de ce que j'ai déjà
quant aux en tant que femme vous osez
vous exprimer sur le foot déjà
ouais c'est vrai mais déjà ne voit
jamais à paris sur le thème qu'est ce
que t'en sais qu est ce que tu que ça
c'est ian cheshire staff et les joueuses
de l'équipe de france de foot féminin
c'est très intéressant parce qu'elle
vous dirais qu'elles veulent elles
veulent pas prendre l'argent des garçons
elles veulent autre chose qu ils veulent
l'argent de capital dit oh non non non